um we'll get on straight away
um
apologies
thank you chair apologies from
councillor gov but councillor pennington
is substituting okay
okay uh
[Music]
thank you thank you
[Music]
i'll go through the pages
page three this is page
number of
i wasn't here but i was just interested
to read the minutes about the peer
reviews taking place in 2023
sorry
what minute 144
b review discussion yeah yeah now we're
getting elected again in 2023
is it going to be before may or after
may that was fast
steve
i believe that should
should actually be 2024.
don't know because
okay
staff would be recruited whether
strategic and identified does that mean
identified a
need
does anybody clear about that
sentence
i think i think that's actually covering
two points of the first part of the
paragraph referring to the team
um for a peer review
and the second bit is looking at uh our
own internal staff linked to a strategic
plan
and identified what
the need is that
the strategic plan had been
approved i approval
yeah
okay
right
page five
page six
uh proposal one second to please
propose simon newton and secondary
cheerlead
uh
okay take the vote
all those in favor
okay
again
i've sent
[Music]
is
that's completed
and
133 qbi2 information um
sean
yeah check if
i haven't had a response yet but perhaps
so far i've picked up with mr harper's
interest doesn't it yeah if i pick up
separately outside the meeting with mr
harper and work out exactly what he
information wants okay we might be able
to get to the bottom whether we actually
hold some of that stuff okay
all right
declarations of interest you all
understand about the declarations of
interest i'm gonna go through again
item six urgent matches brought forth
with the permission on the chair well i
haven't got any
item seven uh agreement of agenda night
in part one and two we've got no part
two
right item a budget medium term finance
strategy
and we have got uh one five
here to do a beautiful report
take it away
thank you chair i apologize for
resources this is largely the same
presentation rather than laughter i
should say overwhelmingly the same
presentation so
apologies in advance
okay what will my presentation cover
well i recap where the council was
essentially this time last year
i'll do a brief refresher on the sources
of the council's finances i'll talk
about the
2022-23 provisional settlements as we've
confirmed i think these
days from central government i'll talk
about some non-settlement related
emerging financial pressures i'll
summarize the key assumptions and risk
in my medium term financial strategy and
projections
i'll go through what does all this mean
for our revenue budgets and sometimes
what this means for the medium term
financial strategy
and i'll cover what the recommendations
are and next steps
so where were we this time last year
well we were predicting that we'd be in
deficits in financial years 2022. well
2021-22 2022-23
202321 returning to a circus in 2024 25
and an increased surplus in 2025-26
and where the council has a deficit we
tend to balance the books by using our
transition in government funding reserve
uh otherwise
referred to as maybe the building
society account
and essentially whilst the transition in
government funding movement would have
to dip into it it'd still have a balance
of 800 000 pounds by the end of 25-26
so
compared with many many councils across
the country this time last year i was
basically saying the council's finances
were in a stable position
next slide please
uh just to recap where do we get our
money from clearly we go from council
tax retain business rates fees and
charges and central government grants
and as the chart shows
the right hand bar the blue the dark
blue you can see a declining percentage
of our income coming from central
government that's a long-term trend
and increasingly we depend on the money
we generate ourselves by the council tax
and also by the
same business rates and fees and charges
and that's by please tom sorry my first
apologies
it's worth reminding members and people
on youtube that's why we're the billing
our tourist district council we actually
collect council tax on behalf of our
preceptors
um
devon county council being the biggest
component with 73 of the council tax
paid by people within the borough
porridge
goes to devon county council
and that's not surprising given their
reach in terms of education social
services children's services et cetera
and highways
and then we have devon and conway police
who have a profit take 12 percent of the
council tax
and the town of paris councils which
take a precept which i think is 56 3
and i can assure you on my original
presentation that three percent was
under the four percent but there we go
not yet tom
uh the share of the council tax bill
that we receive
from our residents is declining and has
been declined for several years
and we're forecasting that 2020 to 23
tourist district council will only
retain eight point three four percent of
the council so it's looking less than
ten percent next time please stop
then this graph
chart picture hopefully gives some
context
given our share the council tax is so
low and that our council tax increases
are capped by referendum restrictions
the impact only increased to torah to
share the overall council tax liability
is minimal for our residents so
we're allowed before having a referendum
restrictions to increase our vandy
council tax by five pounds i'm
predicting i haven't had the free sector
information yet confirmed i know what
they're proposing but hasn't been
confirmed by their various committees
i'm expecting the council tax bill on
average for a bandie property within
tourists to go up by 63.50 which is that
big pile of coins on the left-hand side
of which torridge's share if members
were to agree for a five-pound increase
to a band-aid would only be one of those
coins so i'm just saying as many
decisions we make on our residences and
somewhat minimal
let's find please
however that's not to minimize the
impact upon the council
decisions we make as a council about
increasing cal states have a long-term
profound effect
um back
back in the day probably 2010 2000 2012
councillors decided not to increase the
council tax were compensated back
non-recurrent
council tax freeze grants
and the consequence of that is that we'd
ignored that and not taken
whatever that word the bribe from
central government or the encouragement
from central government and increased
our council tax up to the referendum
limits
we would have collected three and a half
million pounds more council tax and be
four hundred thousand pounds a year
better off than we are today
which the context is roughly what we're
anticipating leisure to cost us in the
financial year 2025 26 onwards next five
please talk
okay we retain 40 of the business rates
and we collect all of business rates
however
we don't set the business rates they're
set by the valuation of this and central
governments
um and so at the moment central
government keep 50 business rates devon
county council getting nine percent of
developments on the second higher again
the weekly party business rates the one
area that's different is where we as a
planning authority awarded planning
permission to renewable energy schemes
such as wind and solar
we keep 100 percent of the business
rating at the moment we keep about 585
000 we retain 100 for the business rates
in certain renewable schemes
fees and charges
uh the council collects just over six
million pounds in fees and charges some
statutory
so
planning fees they're set by central
government clearly because as an
applicant for a planning commission they
don't have a choice as to whether i
can't apply to have an extension of my
house and apply to a council in london
for commission
so their statute some
are calculated on a cost recovery basis
such as land charges and other
in nature
the discretionary fees in charge
generate the most income are parking
garden waste rental councils commercial
properties cemeteries and building
control
and parking and garden waste are by far
the biggest with um the rental about
commercial properties next
next slide please tom
so the 2022 provisional settlement which
is now actually a final assessment we've
only got the email confirmed yesterday
and it hasn't changed there may be some
very smart nuance of the changes but i'm
not expecting it to be in the low
thousands photography at all
the headline figures 3.5 billion extra
plus councils which represents an
increase of over four percent in real
terms for spending power this is
government's criteria how they judge how
generous they've been to local point of
that work
so what is core spending power
well it's central government grants
for us revenue support grant the
services they would grant the lower
taxes the services grant
new homes bonus council tax income and
retained business rate income it's
important to note
that when government make an assessment
of the core spending power of
power of councils they assume
the councils have increased their
council tax up to the referendum limit
and they will also make assumptions
about growth to the underlying tax base
how the number of properties that
councils can charge council tax upon so
every year they're expecting a growth in
the number of properties with the
council from libya council chart charge
on their slack bootstrap
so how was the provisional settlement
for torridge
simple word not good
the left-hand blue the members can read
is torridge and that's one point one
percent
the next one in blue
is shire districts
so that's compared as to how shy of
districts of course spending power has
been and i'm just going to turn around i
can't quite read the figure
that's 4.3 percent
and then there's other
components of government such as unitary
and local such as unitaries counters etc
the yellow bar is inflation and that is
as at a november's cpr and it's actually
got worse consent which was 5.1
so clearly our core spending power has
actually been
decreased below inflation by four
percent with four percent below
replacing our spending power
nets like these
so there's two charts here so on the
first one again we're still 1.1
inflation is the same how do we compare
with the southwest
so the southwest got an average 6.4
increase in its um
spending power and the southwest of
course will include industries such as
devon county council and plymouth and
turkey where they've got social services
and what have you
and the bottom chart there we are again
in blue on the left hand side 1.1
percent inflation 5.1
and the other blue box that's our
um
group of similar councils in same
deprivation so in our deprivation group
then average got
seven percent
and we've got 1.1
so
i don't think it's a starting statement
to say that by any matrix turrets has
not had a good settlement
that's fine please done
okay so what have been the emerging
financial pressures not connected with
the settlement
um
well pleasure
i've stood before you i believe in
december the 6th i went through the
potential costs of leisure going forward
so the blue bar is leisure then we've
got staff related pressures and even to
our vehicle replacement which is
actually a contribution to our vehicle
replacement reserve for the
replenishment replacement of athlete and
pete
please help us in the deputy section 151
go through that in more detail during
his capital presentation
and residual tipping costs next slide
please tom
so what's going the other way what are
the potential savings or additional
income
and the blue bar is business rating
however bear in mind when you see the
business rate income in 2025 26 that's
me making some assumptions about
renewable energies where we can retain
100
so
that's open to the basis of various
legal actions
and future planning applications
uh planning income and broadcasting will
have an electric 250 000 across the
return of the medium temperature i
discussed the risk and uncertainty about
that later in the presentation
and then income from northern burrows
and finally the the bar in yellow have
increased the vapor society by 100 000
pounds i'll discuss very shortly that's
not necessarily a good news story
next slide please tom
so leisure
i report
identified ledger has been the biggest
fat revenue pressure to the council
the median to assume the cost of
providing less this is a key assumption
that will cost the providing ledger will
fall to 450 000 per annum by 2526 and
the income for leisure services is not
anticipated to return to pre-pandemic
levels until 24-25
staffing
staffing's about 70 of our expenditure
and that also offers a big pressure
towards one
is the 2021 pay award
which is 1.75 offered by the
local government association probably
accepted by the unions was greater than
we had in budget because they previously
indicated that there's going to be zero
percent and 250 pounds per gram for
those 724 pounds so we've got a
pressure by under budgeting last year of
the payload
is everybody in the room probably is
aware there's going to be increased
employee and employer national insurance
contributions from the first of april
when they add approximate hundred
thousand pounds of cost to ourselves
and then we've got projected increased
employer contributions for the pension
from 2023-24
also we've got future player awards with
inflationary pressures
that maybe fall upon them
with regards to vehicles i don't know
still um
peter's funded too much but essentially
we need to put more aside into reserve
to replenish the vertical fleet and then
not the next replenishment for the next
replacement of the fleet
and tipping fees we went out to tender
and we've got prices came back and
there's an increased pressure in our tip
of our residual i am at d morning
torrington next month
so as i said
planning income well planning income
as um
the last two years has been
unprecedented essentially it's been
double the budget um the meeting is a
financial strategy assumption 250k
uplift to the budget
northern boroughs we've increased the
time we charge for access to the
boroughs and that's generated additional
income it may also be a staycation
factor in those people have not been
able to go abroad
the vacancy target i've increased the
vacancy target by 100 000 pounds where a
person in
an upside a person is a hgv driver in
our refuge department if they leave
there's no vacancy saving we get an
agency staff straight away because
they're from my service other jobs such
as my job if i was to leave tomorrow we
wouldn't necessarily get an agency staff
in from day one so we do have
natural turnover
and i've increased it one because the
cost of playing stuff is going up with
employers national contributions and the
pension contributions
but also because of difficulties we've
experienced as a counseling recruiting
staff so the recruitment time to replace
stuff is taking longer
um the mean term financial track makes
some modest assumptions regarding the
business rate income and there's other
assumptions about some of the renewable
energy streams may potentially come on
stream next time please
that slide there is just to show you
some of the pressures the council's
facing with regards to inflation
the council doesn't exist in a bubble
separate from the rest of the world it
still has inflation and pressures so at
the at the moment gas is 30 percent uh
electricity i think it shows 25 things
about 18
construction price inflation
and salaries that should say generally
place you know why the slides have all
gone a bit strange so there we go but
most importantly one in yellow is how
much the council taxes we can put it by
so even we put it by the maximum we're
allowed by the referendum limits it's
significantly below inflation
and just for information we're on a
contract among the gas electric which is
due to review in october 2022
so we may see those
price inflation
on the council's gas electric at that
juncture let's buy please so what we
care assumptions while i made an
assumption that council tax will rise by
the referendum for the duration of the
medium term financial strategy
leisure income will return to
pre-pandemic levels by
2024-25 and the cost of providing
leverage services will be served 150 000
per annum by 25 26
there's a leap of faith the pay awards
over the life of the medium term
financial strategy with two percent per
annum
i think the pressure from the unions
will be greater but
i don't believe the employers have the
capacity to do much more
the employers pension contributions will
rise by 1.25 from 23 to 24.
i make no assumption about future
central government review of local
authority needs and resources previously
referred to the fair funding review i.e
what grants we'll get from that you're
not ready any assumptions of them we
carry on with the grants we've got
because the 2023
2022-23 segment was one year long
there's no commitment from government or
any funding many of the years
and i've assumed some additional income
of 250 and 120 respects with respect to
planning northern bureaus that's likely
so
where does that leave us so
in red
that's where we were this time last year
um there's nothing in there's no red in
2627 could have projected that far
forward
in blue that's where i think we are now
um as you can see we don't return to any
semblance of balance until 26
27
that's what i'm projecting
and that's assuming leisure comes back
within an affordable cost envelope
that's fine please stop
and what does that mean on the
transition government funding reserve
the building society account that we tap
into in order to balance our books well
as you can see it goes from 1.8 million
it's coming down to like 1.4 million so
we use
we're using
we start at 1.8 million and we use 1.4
million of that to balance the books
over that period of time
next month please stop
right
just waiting to sometimes the visuals
better than my words
um this is during planet income
so the
aqua
four
columns on the left-hand side of what
planning income was from 1617 to 1920
and as you can see pretty consistent
with that fairly small areas
the next two dark blue
columns
show
what planet income has been from 2021
and what we think will be for 21.22
so
what's the question what should planning
income be
how so i put in 250 000 x per year over
the life of the medium finance central
strategy
i don't know it could drop back to the
aqua days for one of a better expression
next line please
so what happens if members decide not to
raise council tax for 2020 to 23.
so
the blue is the worst position i just
showed you compared with this time last
year the red is the impact and not
raising the council tax for 22 23 we'll
have and you show that we never get back
into balance even by 26 27 we've still
got deficit 136
and we've exhausted
the transition in government funding
reserve and actually gone
overdrawn which we can't actually do for
overdone in the transitioning government
but we've actually haven't got enough
money in the transition of government
funded reserve to balance the books over
that period
next slide please though
so why all the doom and gloom don't we
always understand well we haven't spent
in 21 22 and we've got to understand in
21 and 22 the current financial year but
there's two main reasons
income
[Music]
so basically what i'm saying is there's
been two factors the code with grants
that we've got from government which
have exceeded the actual additional
expenditure we've incurred and planning
income and we've already shown
the variance of planning income for so
if we don't increase so and so that's
why we've had the surface system this
web surface this one last year and the
surface of the food boundary next time
so
you've always glad to know the
presentation's over
the
recommendations actually fall council
either members recommended for council
the torres van d council has to be
increased by five pounds which is 2.9
173 pounds 66 278.66
per year the net revenue budget is 7.993
million and the contributions to and
from reserve is outlandish
and you note my assurances about the
robustness of the budget it's maybe more
you note my assumptions and forecasts
about the budget and the risks as
associated with the mtfs and hopefully
i'll explain the sort of risks of the
figures i've presented to you today and
i'm happy to take any questions before
we go to the recommendations
anybody any questions
new person
yeah did i read something about
the government then subsidies to
people on
the increase in energy is that related
to
the council tax
there's a proposal that um people's
council tax bills will be 150 pounds
less or you will receive a payment of
100 the details not being worked through
we only got this on friday in a response
to increased energy bills so basically
whatever the way it will work if we give
everybody if we're not 150 pounds of
everybody's bill
we will be compensated by government
from that so it makes no impact on the
figures are presented to you but we will
not lose an account no we will get and
we call it new burdens funding so we
will
do the administration of it but we'll
receive compensation for the money we
don't collect
philly
yeah i just wanted to ask a question on
page 27
and
it is halfway down three little points
there that talks about reducing levels
of service in a mandatory services
now that do we provide services over and
above the knee of what we have to do
purely on a mandatory basis because that
bullet point indicates
there may be some surplus saving
if we are giving over and above what
we're required to do in mandatory ways
well managing could be a things
planning applications within x number of
days
and if we lost the planning officer
false we may do it in longer but still
within statutory
scales
okay but what does the bullet point
i mean
the services of the council if we don't
find additional income or reduce
non-status services we will have to find
some ways of reducing the level of
mandatory services while still meeting
our statutory obligations
but you'll just be less good okay you
know so what is the difference between
mandatory
a statutory obligation i don't think
that i think it publishes his word
it's consistent and managing station
is the same word okay so it's so so is
there any difference then between the
services that we are now supplying that
are
well perceived don't necessarily have to
provide them but we don't have to do
parts and open spaces
but that's not a monetary service it's
not statutory services accounts not a
statutory dose not we can do away with
parties we can do away with that we have
choices i'm talking now about purely
mandatory services like refuge selection
we can't we can not have a planning
service we can't not process housing
benefit claims okay but we cannot
collect council taxes
is worded
would imply that we are doing over and
above what we are mandatory or statutory
required to do well i mean
just for example we pay in my team
98 or 99 of all our invoices within 14
days
we're not obliged to be able to bet
we're right to pay our creditors clearly
yeah
but we could i suppose if worse comes to
the words we could cut that level of
service that we give to the businesses
at college okay so is there any saving
there is no savings
we'd have to look into that
but we're not obliged to give free
application advice for instance okay but
we do provide that service yeah yeah
we're not obliged to meet our customers
as often as we do we could cut down on
that sort of thing
so so there are cost efficiencies you
could make to your statutory services
but they might be the sort of cost
efficiencies you want to make so are we
we are charging for our pre-op service
yeah it doesn't wash its face
it doesn't wash it no
by how much i couldn't tell you exactly
thanks to the peninsula but
you know we're very very cheap because
what we see is that it makes us it makes
for a better service and makes for a
better outcome right
so we're subsidizing right
yes okay
so there may be areas that you may look
into that this bullet point that's all
i'm suggesting
chair
steve do you want to say something
yeah i'm just just going to add um i
just checked on the recommendations
there's a recommendation to
the full council to establish a working
group to look at how the budget could be
um
reduced over
the median term and they are the types
of things that working group would look
at the different services and how costs
could be reduced
but obviously taking into account the
impact on the service on our customers
who produce it soon so that'll be part
of a longer
a longer debate kind of work for
veterans
this committee should be doing that
not not something soaked out from from
full council
that's part of our job
i mean so how we get around that i'm not
quite sure yet
how could we get rounded but
for this committee to do that
it was a recommendation for council to
consider so we'd have to bring it up
before council
surely that is a that is an area of
policy or policy construction
it's not necessarily
overview or scrutiny of policy so i
would not necessarily concur with you
that it does sit in this committee
i would have thought actually it's this
committee that would look at the results
of of what
what is determined by a working group um
that's possible but then then we look at
doing two lots of work
in my opinion you you offered a separate
group set up then we bring it back to it
for us to look at which provided tests
other people's thinking it's all down to
taking much longer than you need to
in my opinion but fine we will we'll
cross that bridge when we get to it um
who's next
steve
i mean one way might be to ask about
futures
so that it gets picked up
i think this discussion has
recognize that there's areas where they
mix and it's more difficult
too
but i think mapping exercise where the
council can actually at least see that
would be a good outcome to work through
okay right
i think the recommendation from seeing
out of all councils at a working group
for membership to be determined by full
council looking ways to bring the
budgets back into balance
so that covers welcomes both scenarios
from 2070 you talk about raising charges
but no exercise has been done so far
about
like what the indicator what we could
actually increase
well that's why imagine the working
group would look if i'm being honest and
i don't want to
think too far ahead of my monitor
actually quite a detailed piece of work
that would actually involve quite
significant input from my team and being
honest in terms of granting bridges and
explaining to members what budgets they
are what those departments do yeah
[Music]
um
david
informed us at the very paltry song that
we got and i think we were
shared his shock and horror
comparatively to the rest
of
the area and that we were we fell far
below so um
quite rightly
david responded to the settlement and
queried why we only had this 1.1
i haven't caught up with
the information you had yesterday so i
apologize for that
um but we actually raised it with our
um six weekly meeting with
sir jeffrey cox and said please we look
into this
because we
couldn't understand
the formula that had been used to
actually arrive at this 1.1
and we were really concerned that
um this is only a one-year settlement
but would it color the future
so that when um settlements were being
considered for the following year it
might they might look back and say well
if we just give them a little bit extra
this year will be better than it was
last year or indeed they've managed so
we'll we'll peg it at that so you just
because there is no published formula on
the detail it's a very complex
methodology
we were in the dark
so jeffrey agreed to raise it
with michael go but i think michael berg
has been rather occupied in other areas
um and i don't know whether we've heard
anything from
uh steve's shaking his head we haven't
heard anything from geoffrey fox's
office
and perhaps um
david could you elucidate
what the response was about your appeal
it's not an appeal it's an inquiry
and i received no response for the
official
the actual link to the final settlement
who knows
i may be pleasantly surprised and found
that you know our summit has gone up a
few thousand pounds but nationally it
hasn't moved in any significant degree
so we're most surprised if any
in his room favor with the torridge in
the final settlement
the biggest influence will be there's a
combination of two things but one thing
would be the decline in our new homes
has been more severe than other councils
so that's what they do is you have new
one bonus that plummets and all the the
only protection you have as new on bonus
points is your cost spending power will
never be zero
i've never come into council tax and
have ended up going into business rates
and holiday homes that could be a factor
and it could be a factor that our tax
base has been slightly undermined by
houses that were previously on council
tasks
moving into business rates because the
increase and liability of holiday homes
but
the actual detail
is
just get on my intellectual capacity to
tell you to go into this the um
particular finals okay right
next cheryl
is there anything more we can do as a
council to lobby for increased
i appreciate that you are already
looking into it but as full council
people
do something more
because to be four percent below
inflation just seems
pretty unfair
to the final settlements being published
this week uh so once that
improvement
that would be it um it's very rare that
there's any retrospective adjustments
uh made to financial settlements um the
idea is
office
um as we haven't had a response i mean
the only change you've made now that
they actually got
something actually wrong
you know in the calculations of the
actual actual error now it's been set by
government now
it requires the expertise of people like
lg futures who summarize those charts
for you
um 100 you said uh david i remember
rightly in your address just now
um
actually for the planning committee if
we know we want to keep all from the uh
torridge we're going to be under
pressure to approve any um renewable
energy situation we've got coming in so
i i was wondering if there is a problem
there that's always been the case
sometimes it's always been the case yes
there's 585 000 pounds a year that we
couldn't get 100 off that's built above
several years okay so it's not this
isn't a new thing that's come in that's
always been the case i've been going for
years well it's been the case since i
think 2013.
so
next two questions
one is a declare of personal interest
because we have land that is affected by
this new cabling route for the moroccan
array that's coming across
um to webery and cuts right from
cornwall all the way through
are we going to get any money from that
because that is renewable it will
provide about eight percent of the uk
domestic electric supply
and i don't know um if we are asking
those questions and the second out of
that one is should torres be proactive
in promoting more um solar and wind
power in this area to actually um gain
business rates so we have an advertising
arm we like a proactive arm
to to actually earn more money um
for our district
on the first question i don't know about
the could be under national
infrastructure
so there's certain national
infrastructure things which that don't
come to the business rates at a tourist
level but i think follower produces
about a hundred thousand pounds a year
for that community over there rightly
yeah that that's uh that's separate uh
to the uh business rate so that's where
the communities give
um an allocation from them from the
company
um and as you said you you referred
transparency to the financing we don't
put things like that in the planning
documents because it's not material
consideration or the connection
um but should we have a proactive arm um
you guys in that direction
um
council peninsula i suspect it would be
something for the working group to
consider um if you're looking at
generating additional income or
reduction in costs then that would be
something
[Music]
you can't put it through the plane
can
sorry
john um i think i think if this council
was to adopt or even consider adopting a
very proactive
income generation strategy for the
delivery of additional
wind and energy
programs it would be part of our
strategic plan
and at the moment and that would have to
be um something that was decided by full
council
considering all the ramifications from
promoting something like this
at the moment it's not embedded in that
um it is a subset obviously about income
generation
um but it's something that it would not
be just a small group
no area designated for it because
it was taken out of the
local plan but
i think we realize now now we are
looking into the local plan again
that yes we're going to have to
designate areas i think
for for wind
and so on you know because
i mean we we talk about solar
and and getting 100
business rate from it we've
we've got a judicial review coming up
for one that's just gone off of
fireworthy
that that that we approved
that that's all gone into limbo until
the judiciary movement provided they
raised the money to do with jesus
you know
we're waiting for a few months time
anyway any more questions sorry share
them
to look at
renewables in its own properties on its
own buildings
so
[Music]
that's an exercise that should take
place
just look at that building down there
not that can generate solar energy for
instance so i think that's important
part of the income generation
um it's just another question i don't
know whether it's relevant i'm just
interested to know how um
allocations in the budget go to
particular departments and how it's all
worked out and in terms of climate
change how the budget for that is worked
out whether it's relevant
well clear the council invested in a
climate change officer
that we shared i believe with north
bevin and there is a small
that we set aside to fund reports and
projects
but clearly
as i won't go into it now because people
go through this we've highlighted it on
the capital programme the decision
whether we go electric combatants and
the issues pertaining to that and it'll
just if it comes through
uh if
that's the way we go then that'd be a
budget we may have to add to a huge one
realistically in all seriousness
probably we need external funding to
deliver on our climate change agenda
um
we won't deliver the existing resources
net carbon zero i wouldn't think in our
existing would have some kind of
external support
this core spending power because it just
seems to fall in today
we're so much lower than other areas i
mean if we don't get any joy
or any satisfactory answer from jeffrey
cox can we as a council or can our
leader or whatever um
go very public without this quiet about
this in terms of using the medium and
stuff like that because it just
it's just unfair
yeah yeah
steve you want to answer that
[Applause]
so yes we could
very difficult though i mean fighting
that's the central government
i mean
we we had a new owned bonus which made
us lovely money then they found out that
we were doing really well so they took
it away which is normal
yes joke sorry
thank you
i just forgot to point out it's not just
the um
spending of uh
local authorities i mean education in
the west coast we've been in toronto in
particular and it's always fallen out
well well well you know a national
average it's just something that
historically we've always had in
torridge
we've always accepted that we haven't
kept up too much of a fuss and i think
question because i said a lot like oh
yeah um
i'm struggling a bit um can i ask where
we are with the coastal tax reduction
scheme because i think we've got one of
the harshest in devon and given the
changes for working age families coming
up on the first of april with the
national insurance etc etc
um
a lot of families are going to be
struggling at the present moment and i
note that cnr back in the august meeting
had an unaudited
surplus of 771 000 pounds to the ledger
fund
and that must seem a bit hard
for for for working age families and it
is a bit personal because i my wife have
done become pensioners in the last 18
months which is very nice indeed thank
you very much um we just will pass
school every four weeks and pick up a
nice little sum of money um and we don't
pay national assurance any longer it
seems totally unfair
and we have a an age difference a
generational difference of benefits
coming and i do struggle where we are so
harsh on our cultural tax reduction
scheme when we are asking to put up
potential tax returns by five pounds um
i'm not gonna hold against today but i
suspect that i will abstain on that
ground because i am worried about
the impression that money is going to
leisure when hard-working families from
the first debate group are going to fade
wage uh face um
energy cost rises and national insurance
rises to pay for the care um that
will be for me in about five years time
i suspect but let's
see where it gets there um but that's
where i'm coming from do you want
anything uh yes thanks uh thanks
councilman and i won't comment too much
on your harshness of um
compared to others i know we've had many
conversations over the years in that
respect and it's not uh comparing quite
comparing apples with apples
in terms of where we are with our
current scheme it was approved at full
council before christmas to roll over
the existing scheme and that was largely
on the basis that due to the impact of
the pandemic
the team haven't had the resource to
review the team
scheme in sufficient detail to recommend
anything different a member working
member officer working group has been
set up i think i've met once
to look at how the scheme might be
revised for 2023-24
so reports will be coming forward during
this year to look at the revised scheme
i don't comment on the the detail of
that yet uh it should be unbelievable so
okay
just respond on that one
yeah come on phil well certainly i just
hope you look at the pension age group
as well and if they are sure they should
also contribute they should be fair
across all generations and there should
be a generational difference i hope the
working group will address a fairness
across the generations i've been council
penalties pensioners are protected in
the house it's our support scheme so
that's not within the leaders of the
council
i i pick up the comments that uh it's
central government's uh dick pic that we
but we can challenge that if we wish to
as a council
but the there's clearly in the
legislation that we cannot um
do that to the pensioners so pensioners
are protected essentially in the old
arrangements but i think as officers you
have a responsibility to strategize your
duties we as counsellors have to find
the policies that we wish to put forward
and that's our role as councillors
okay fine thank you i finished it thank
you thank you yeah
you're the last one
oh
all right you you as well you could be
the last one
in
the authority that collects the council
attacks
are we penalize if we don't get the full
amount
yeah apart from
so for example whatever's not collected
in council tax there's a bad debt
calculation made obviously county
council demon county council will bear
73 percent of them
by
4 the police 12
and we bear
our share and the town of irish councils
right that's it for that
yeah
so if we pursue someone
and through the courts are we recommend
trying clinton we we received the core
costs associated with that so we put our
core cost of i think at 65 pounds we as
the billing authority keep the full 65
pounds but the thousand pounds we may
collect on somebody we'll only get 8.34
percent well we'll get twelve percent
we'll get the powerful town council's
share as well so
cheryl
your last
um
i would put for the proposal that this
committee registered our
we just don't do anything about it and
just sit and take it so
just send the letter to the central
government saying that it's not fair and
we've already been talking about it here
excited about that would we have to we
would just have to go to full council
don't worry
can i come in here we've already
raised this
with our member of parliament
who has given his commitment to raise it
with the secretary of state
we have already said today that because
we have not had a response we will
escalate this and actually write to him
again
and ensure that this council's concerns
and we can add to that
that it is the concerns of the
um
community and resources committee and
now the overview and scrutiny committee
that this seems to be um
an inappropriate settlement
and they are concerned and wish to
challenge it and i think that
is the act the course of action i i
can't make any recommendations i'm not
part of this community but i think that
should be
uh
would be far more effective
than just
as we are already discussing with
jeffrey collins it seems to be the right
way to go
uh for me because anyway because we've
already got a foothold into central
government
uh and and he can talk to whatever
minister he asked him
and so i think that that would be the
best way to go personally to another
sender letters to central government
that will get
probably get lost but if we do it
through jeffrey cox
then we know we've done it well then we
can report back to this committee yeah
that's right and
community and resources okay philly last
one yeah that's why i go back to work
with storage i've got the peer review
challenge of
may 2013
reading the minutes before i came i
thought i'd dig out the peer review
challenge
and it says on 3.53
there needs to be a much greater
appreciation engagement in
um
and influencing beyond origin in order
to maximize possible benefits from
communities the political and funding
decisions with the biggest impact on
courage
through which to develop greater
influence in order to start punching at
or above its way
that was in our peer review and to take
what are different you're saying is
falling short of what we went through on
a period last night
already at
period
um what what does that say what does it
say in the 2018.
we do not try to pump it up away we just
sit there well
can i respond to that because um since
becoming deputy leader and the new
administration um
has been led by ken james
um
we have introduced
a dialogue with our mp
and with others bodies across devon
to increase our status and to lobby
effectively
um so we have moved on before this
administration was elected
there were no meetings between our mp
and the leader and the chief exec
this has all worked really well we've
raised all sorts of issues
and the status i believe of torridge we
are no longer no longer referred to as
where's tom
when we go to meetings and uh the leader
and our chief exec and the team have
worked incredibly hard to ensure that we
get really good representation and i
know your concerns because i too have
read both those reports and was
concerned that we were not outward
looking we weren't going and seeking
uh information we've been seeking
funding we've worked hard together to
raise the profile of torridge
and i don't think it's helpful to say
that we're not doing it okay
okay
wait
wait
i think we should change this through
jeffrey cox
give jeffrey cox something to really do
for torridge
in my opinion
so i'd still like to cut forward yeah we
do have to go to work yeah okay we've
got you know but it can be it's like to
be you as backup to what you're already
doing
before we go to the vote can we just
have cheryl to repeat the proposal
yeah yeah come on cheryl repeat it
do you want to say something
charles was going to say perhaps it
would help if we do prove this to
publicize it widely in the community
that we are suffering badly as a
council
you know maybe that will um
to jeffree cross as well
cheryl what exactly do you want to say
as i said yeah i mean i
i take clare i
i i hear exactly what you're saying and
and i admire it completely and if those
links are there and they're working
really well
and i trust you but the proof will be
whether we get a response and whether we
get a decent response that answers the
worries we've got i mean on that basis
i'm quite happy i don't know how to
share with you i'm quite happy to say
let's wait
and see what happens and then if you
come back and say
we haven't got any joy and he hasn't
come back with anything satisfactory
then we take it a step further i mean
what you're saying is that you don't
think that a general letter the central
government would be a step further
to be quite honest we've tried this
thing before we've sent in
the central government and i think we've
had one in there for i don't know how
long now and we've had no answer at all
so if we go if we try and do it through
for me if we try and do it through
jeffrey fox which we should be giving
jeffrey cox the work to do
uh and and let him chase it for us
then if nothing comes with that then we
can look at it
in the way that you and cheryl say you
want to do it if that's my opinion but
you know
if you agree with that that's fine
if it helps
um i will make a commitment to this
committee and i'm sure backed up by the
chief exec that we will report back you
will report progress and our response
you will report back
we will
simon you you you you watch um
ladies and gentlemen dates of reality
if you have a point
which is
owned by
and championed by a member of parliament
um a senior member of parliament even if
he's not a member of government uh you
will get
way way deeper into the bureaucracy of
state than you will if you send
a general letter from a council of which
government receives thousands of letters
from councils every month
and they probably make pretty other than
the cursory clubs
you are just one in a thousand if you've
got an mp who well actually is
sponsoring something and he can walk
into another person's office he can walk
into
the secretary of state's office or the
outer office and put it on the permanent
side of his desk and say make sure
you're possible or whatever that is how
business works
and that's how the world goes around um
so yeah you can make a
you can make an electoral statement if
you want so it goes in the paper but it
what they're doing at the moment is is
the way to progress
[Music]
thank
because this is why we're in such a part
of the reason why
we're in the situation we're in and all
we're trying to do is say what can we do
what can we do to change this okay i may
be seeing it very simplistically i don't
know but that's where we're coming
you know
i will trust what you're saying and if
you're going to bring something but the
proof will be in seeing if he does get
the answer that you're saying he will
get yeah
[Music]
[Music]
reasonably regular with jeffrey collins
you know and and i do understand where
it comes from i used to have a meeting
with jeffrey cox myself with
with planning with the planning
department
sure we only get more percent on our
government brand and that's the proof of
the party where we are at the moment and
that's on your ground this morning and
that's the evidence that we had before
us
or
george oh
um
we're not getting very far
fine okay right
cheryl come on back and then
nick laws can have a guy and then we
finish then we go through a
recommendation our local residents will
be asking why are we putting up cancer
attacks again and we need to be able to
tell them well look central government
has given us four percent below
inflation so it's a way of sort of
telling people this is how we're being
treated so
if we do vote to increase capital then
you can kind of understand why we need
to because central government aren't
helping us
so i would still propose
this is not sending a letter that won't
be read by anybody it's just registering
our concern as a committee to jeffrey
cox
just
showing that we're concerned and then
the committee can be added to whatever
the leader
deputy leader and chief executive are
doing to lobby for it on their
themselves because like shows everybody
trusts what they're doing and they're
doing very good job through
as we get findings they can come back to
this committee
and david wants to save them yes sorry i
just do want members to be
the mistaken impression that just if we
were to get a inflation
settlement of the close spending pound
but magically all our problems have
disappeared um you know leisure is still
the most significant factor and also
the pressures that we've got on our
staff cost and just general inflation
which i alluded to you know the
utilities and et cetera so
whilst
you know when i got the settlement and i
digested it on whatever day they came
through and you know
somewhat disappointed and when updating
the median term financial strategy i
don't want members to think that that's
the panacea of all our problems if we
were to magically get very cost-spending
settlement on or around the inflation
level other colleagues
across devon and i think west evan got
close to inflation 4.6 they're still
looking at very significant deficits
across their medium-term financial
strategy so they didn't manage to think
that was the one answer
[Music]
okay
nick
surely just a one-line email to jeffrey
saying i do have to tell you jeffrey
this is becoming more urgent the
counselors of this committee
i've been very agitated today to learn
how serious the thing is please board it
urgently yeah
we could do that but it has to be done
between between and
and
yes and then we can we can take it from
the last one
last one i have to just comment uh that
what cheryl said that
just because the
the allocation is is short of inflation
that does not mean that we would not be
putting up council tax by our maximum of
five pounds a year uh or 2.5
uh we would still be doing that so don't
try to blame this on the council tax
rights because it would be going up
anyway because we know we all know what
happens if we don't take that that um
that amount and the amount of money
we've lost in the past
absolutely
anyways anyway we need to get on there
oh god
we've got a proposal and a
what do you want to say cheryl you need
to
give this community
[Music]
okay
did you get that yeah
yeah got it
right okay put it to the phone
all those in favor
how many
four all those again
abstentions
are you obtaining then
will it i i've ordered a favorite oh
sorry i didn't see that oh sorry that's
right
okay that's fine
so that's a lot but
but we will still
sort out mr cost yeah
okay
again jen's here yeah yeah i think at
the moment we've asked him to do it and
we should remind him
yeah okay
and then we will pursue it okay that's
fine that's good
i guess we're assuming uh sir jeffrey
hasn't done anything uh as councilman
hudson pointed out
okay
we have recommendations
um
we've got recommendation
to full council for a b and c should we
take these all together or do you want
to do them single all together a b and c
yeah the three top
bollywood council
proposer
it's very odd
to find out who's uncommitting not with
because it's been so close together
against
abstention
one abstinence
right okay
so uh and
the next ones are just for note okay
um
do we
know we know those okay
yeah right
right david
yes ken could i just go back to one
thing
what what back to where about the um
settlement i don't know whether steve
had it but i had an email made last
night from
the
department of leveling up and hosing
and i'll just quote you one part of two
paragraphs one is i've published the
final local government finance
settlement for 2023 this segment makes
available an additional 3.7 billion to
councils in england
an increase
in mental authority funding of over four
and a half percent in real terms
this will ensure rules across an event
have the resources they need to deliver
and i'll just quote the second one this
follows consultation on the provisional
settlement we received 148 responses
from across england and these responses
have been given full consideration
so
that came out last night to say that
they've agreed the supplement
they have had responses and i take it
we've
[Music]
somebody from the district council's
finance forum she was on the meeting
yesterday she said essentially which is
true
there's been some secret of the figures
at a national level i actually wouldn't
expect any changes to any individual
if it's foreign because i need to get
into the detail but there wasn't the
link on the anonymous i could see it's
the actual detail location sorry
district council but i've lowered
everybody's expectations
right okay all right
thanks for that david number question
for david and you know are you going
doug
very cold
we haven't finished yet
i've seen it once before
okay dave
can you replace him
um so i'm gonna update uh
oh
[Music]
um yeah so i'm just going to run through
the updates to capital programme for yes
so we're going to cover the current
program updated for the next five years
and this includes
updating the forecasts for the spend and
receipts that we have come in um and
also inflation updates which is
obviously a big topic at the moment
on both the vehicle program which is
mainly all our refuse vehicles um but
also
build costs and 10 price inflation which
covers most of our other capital
projects
um we'll then have a look at the new
events that have been submitted um also
pressures from the leisure program and
the move to electric vehicles which is
coming in future years
um
from this we will have a look where that
leaves us with the gap and the shortfall
um have a look at the vehicle program
longer term for updating of the fleet
and the money we've contributed from the
revenue budget that's going towards that
and then we'll also look at the general
program and
where we are and where that leads us for
going forward
so this is where we started the year so
last february full council approved the
program at
roughly 24 million and which gave us a
slight surplus
so from there we've updated it with um
adjustments of funding which is um
additional receipts and some right to
buy receipts we get on the council board
housing and also forecast adjustments
from
surfaces from last year and some of that
was contributed and also adjustments to
the new home bonus we also have the dfg
program which is the disabled facilities
grant so this is largely grant funded
this is extended out
um which contributes to it so that gives
us an updated program of
26 um
26 million with a bit of extra funding
which actually gives us a surplus of 2.6
million
we then look at the vehicle program and
although some inflation built into it
across the
current rates that we're seeing in
vehicle inflation so this has been
updated and increased and that adds to
it
um
we also
extend the program for an addition
so
so then so this comes down to the timing
of the vehicles and that there's some
additional funding which is actually our
current revenue contribution to that
so this reduces us
surplus to 2.3
so from there we look at the
inflation and this is on building cost
inflation so this is this comes from
rick's
institute of child surveillance um so
from there october um
output basically from the pcis we get
some of the pressures we can see that
material prices got by 16.9 percent from
the 12 months to october
and
they've got continued forecasting um
rising inflation for another 15 percent
sort of five years
but this sort of in summary gives us
general building costs from nine percent
higher
um
which all adds to our programs
so from this um
with the property manager we've
identified twelve projects that we
currently have in the program and which
are impacted by this type of inflation
um these 12 projects add up to roughly
10 million
largely because the environmental sense
is included in that which is 7 million
so we look to apply
approximate value of inflation 10
percent
over 977 000 pounds into our current
program just
increased
just to keep up with inflation
so this will reduces
the surplus we currently got down to
about 1.4 million
so from there we look at the new heads
so this is a list of the new pins which
were submitted
so these
vary across different sectors so we've
got female lane refurbishment we've got
the move
revenue office service to digital
offering we've got um the disabled
access pathways outside this building
there's also the ground maintenance
equipment which was actually um
already been approved by food council
because this
service has been brought back in-house
so that the criminal has to be
purchased in this year
refurbishment
and we've got sandy mirror road there's
actually two pins for san diego road
that's the more expensive one and then
there's two options
then we've got electric vans so
within our vehicle program we already
have the we have the vans within there
are just the traditional
traditional diesel versions so these two
kids are for the additional cost of
making those vans electric
last week i believe and again this was
due to some of you um get access to the
grant funding because there were time
limits on
so if we include all these um new bids
then this would reduce us to a surplus
of
just under 400 000.
so along with the new bids we've also
got some additional pressures um this is
from both
leisure and mutual electric vehicles so
leisure
initial assessments indicate that
the current three sites require about
six hundred thousand pounds of capital
work just to bring them back up to a
suitable standard
um and then we also anticipate
approximately sixty thousand pounds per
site per year um just to
capital maintenance requirements
so we already have some of this in in
the current program so we've got 350 000
in there at the moment
um but i think it'd be prudent to add or
to at least a
forecaster the additional 60 will
require going forwards
now we also have
there was some money put into the
leisure reserve last year and that's
where the 521
funding contribution comes in
so the electric
vehicle updates so there are two kids in
there um proposed move to electric um
but long story about we have
24 approximately 24 smaller bands so
this this isn't this isn't the larger
refuse vehicles um
it's currently a suitable offering to
move those to electric um although i
know the refuse manager is looking at
some options
um but i think they're down the road
this is just for the smaller bands and
this is just an estimate that
if we when the current bands um
at the end of their useful lives we can
replace them to electric um there'd be
an extra source 320 to seven 000 and
there's quite a big assumption that
electric gets cheaper in the years
to come down almost come down to the
cost of the current
so it will take a step back for a second
so really our program splitting up this
is splitting out the vehicle program so
the vehicle program which is all our
refuse bag and wagons and the smaller
bands so we can split our current
um shortfall um of 300 000 we have after
adding the measure of the electric
um
about half is the vehicle program and a
half is the general
so first we look at the vehicle program
this is this comprises 30 large refuse
recycling super vehicles and smaller
banks
now
if we look at the current cost to
replace all of our vehicles this comes
to approximately
4.7 million and an average life of about
seven years
so that would equate to 675 000 pounds a
year across the council
at the moment we contribute from the
revenue um
5500
so
this this is why we currently do the
555 000 it's because when we started um
contributing sort of saving up for the
next purchase of the next large fleet
replacement of the vehicles
um
we already had some
money in reserves for the vehicles plus
we also put the sale and the three
depots into them
so with that 555 000 that gets us enough
money in the pot to purchase the next
round of and replace our large vehicles
in 26 27.
um the
problem with that is if we continue
um putting aside 5000
and by
by the time that fleet requires
replacing in 3233 we'll actually have 3
million or 3.2 million sure
so
therefore it's proposed to increase the
contribution from the revenue budget by
a hundred thousand
um today
and then basically get money at sign
and then increase that also by inflation
in the years ahead and that basically
means that we have balanced long-term
refuse vehicles
although there's a challenge
no this isn't including any move to
election
and um
[Music]
but there are some significant pressures
um over the next few years which this
isn't
included
so if we're looking over the next five
years
um
although we've already got a short fall
small shortfall that there's no
[Music]
property managers etc in discussions
with environment agency and this is this
is still a little way off but there's
quite a big project
in the future um
generally which is sort of require
significant funding from torridge so
we've just got an estimated figure in
there one and a half million
um as i've already said there's got
nothing in for electric or hybrid refuse
vehicles
and we've also got some
um it pressures when our current desktop
license is run until 2024 and then we'll
require a required extension there's
also fall under checks
so all this together gives us sort of
extra pressures over the year ahead of
three
3.75 million
um
um
so that's where we are so then
we come to recommending the pits so
current this current shortfall of 177
000 um is in the context of all these
kids being approved
so
each of these videos
and therefore recommendations
so each kid has a
project visible score and a financial
score
so the project score is scored by the
leader the chief exec and the section
151 alpha 100
and
the new
process was also recommends a quality
bar so where we recommend each project
is assessed
um out about 100 and that really the
council should look to recommend
projects um above 65 and get above the
60 values 465. we also do a financial
score to allow their comparison um where
each point represents 100 000 power
costs
so here are the um
suggested pits and their scorings
um
[Music]
for this year so we've got
so we've got um
brands makes it's actually running
groups we've actually got four
above the line and five below um
from
previous meetings
there was a preference over the lower
cost for san diego
so just in summary we've got a
current short form of 177 000 however if
we
only recommend the bids which come above
the quality bar this actually becomes a
surplus of 460 000 pounds within the
program
but this needs to be looked at within
the context of actually future pressures
of getting close to four million so so
when locals come about we're gonna have
to fight a big gap
so move on to the recommendations
so these are the group recommends to
full council
um the capital program is updated
building cost inflation um the vehicle
program is updated
for inflation and the vehicle program is
balanced long term by increasing the
revenue contributions
and also lastly the bits meet the
minimum recommended project score of 65
are included in capital programs and
that's the fourth pizza
and it's also worth saying which i
didn't mention before that
puppets which
are not recommended
um
they're fall below the score they can
still be referred back to offices for
further work and refining
um and possible future consideration
that's it
anybody got a question for john
[Music]
have we have looked into it in the past
that we're in the fortunate position
where we can borrow
cheaply from the pwlb public works loan
board and actually generally most least
in options come at much higher finance
costs so over the long term doesn't
doesn't it isn't does not become the
cheaper option
but it's something we sort of
theoretically haven't
looked at
anybody else's question
oh actually
thank you for your report
um
just on the leisure
program
that 900k
it's 60k per site per year
15 sites i take that to represent
and then we're talking about our three
leisure science centers okay there's the
three letter centers okay
why is this in the capital budget when
it should be an expenditure
if it's an annual basis because we're
complying this will come back year after
year after year again yeah it's it's an
estimation of the annual cost so it
won't be a
exactly 60 years it's a rough budget so
but what it
sort of um
looks to
so we look at the caps like so that's
items which are over ten thousand pounds
[Music]
771 k from the unordered
surplus transferred to the legislature
last year is that in addition to this
900 000 or is it including this 900
that was included within on this funding
site so i think
of that
750 171 i think
250 roughly is to sell the
side sector company
about 516
funding which is included
which is being put towards that fact
okay so then we come back to this 900k
we've taken a 180k
for the three swimming pools
and we're left with 720k in this budget
um
the 900 is first
is an estimate that will be required
over the next or five years
saying
but it's for capital works and it's not
expended sure that's coming through the
capital program
okay thank you for your interest thank
you
anybody answer any questions
cheryl
i was just gonna ask about the funding
um
so the pathways that come into capstone
is that covered by disabled grants
um no there's no grant funding on that
that's all out of council resources
[Music]
to allow them to live in their own homes
it's not
for us to use by our own council
premises so you know you can you need to
scan a stairlift or something like that
that's what disables facilities plans
for it's not for us to spend on our own
infrastructure so there's no type of
grant for the council for that type not
from disabled facilities
[Music]
and i'm surprised that it's gonna cost
four to six thousand pounds to reach
circus a few rants come up
and it seems like a lot of money
is that literally just to resurface the
purpose to come up with like
46 pounds
just to do that
yeah detailed in your head
what works will be done yeah
the details bid documents are not
attached to the committee reports for
obvious reasons because contractors will
have sites with the detail so the paid
documents were shared with members in
detailed workshop
um
october november
early december 7th december
okay
cheryl
um i know some of our
counsellors actually park
so that they don't have to come up that
way they've park here aside so you don't
have to go at the steps in the slope is
that not an option
is that being considered
so to do well so
in normal times it's a very busy
facility
a lot more tenants on site have so as we
return to normality many of those spaces
will be used yeah and at their current
state play in those
they're such standards uh they need um
spec in that's where most of the
visitors park tends to be the parking
lot here is what's immense sometimes
this is not normally for gap cancels the
bug
but all of that you don't normally find
space
in your own times yeah
just for clarity purposes
the issue we've got is signage because
you know
just outside of this building there are
two probably good disabled bays
parking maze which you know uh lock
users and i mean yeah um
so they're literally very good all the
way forward into the main end the one
that's important is that there's two
disabled bases at the bottom which
divided and maybe moving a
there aren't disabled-based error the
answer really is to save 46 asian bands
and put it into
more important like measure facilities
i'm sorry the play equipment in victoria
park for example that will be
more for the way spending them there
needs to be adequate scientists
directing disabled users to come and use
this this facility up here
but are those two
disabled parking spaces they're actually
yes they're followers
so what you what you have here the 26
service offices on site yes that in
normal times have a lot of people
working on them you have a lot of people
coming to visit those businesses that
are on site you have two conference
facilities here that in normal times can
uh house approximately 100 people
and then you've got the registry office
and all the other activity that's going
on the site so as you can imagine you
will find days where this is
chock-a-block all around and you've got
a big meeting you know all of that is
basically pretty cool
so so i think there's probably a greater
requirement moving forward with our
demographic for more distinctive spaces
um
so as it stands i'm not sure that we can
no i don't think we can direct it that
way i think we need disabled spaces
there as well
right okay i think i'm different okay
okay
i just want to say that i'm disappointed
about the touring park because
i think
that um
the play strategy said that victoria
park would be
uh or somewhere will be carried out
there this year
and i think if it's not on these kids
then i don't i can't see that happening
so the play statute
or that part of it fails
that's
my view of it
yeah thank you yeah
this is an estimated figure 46 000 i
understand which covers
um
sort of a range of work researchers
seeing new timber et cetera but i'm
going to take a point from
which could perhaps minimize the amount
of work needed
on on the
path
also take the point about the facility
just around the corner there
do we have this early opportunity to
revisit that estimate in terms of
looking at specifications
to come back again because obviously we
found seven block councils having
serviced out that's money outdated there
and obviously as climate change
remember i'm concerned about the low
priority given to the under the 165
given to eb vehicles i mean what's going
to happen um are we going to have to buy
diesel and they're by not
you
[Music]
um the process and methodology that this
committee set up and approved
so it's it's your scoring mechanism that
we have used to support the projects
um and as is uh highlighted in the
report whilst some of the pits fall
below school currently
uh
they should be referred back to officers
to further investigate so if if there's
opportunities of additional funding for
example that would put that might might
award push the score
so what comes from council or after we
decided we bounced on this there's the
opportunity to come back and say what is
it
so it has to be the full council service
because young council is setting the
final program
stay tuned
coming back on the point on the electric
vehicles councillor haines and that's
been looked at by the teams extensively
it's been reviewed by richard hayes it's
been reviewed by donna sibley our
climate officer they're not fit for
purpose at the moment they will not do
the job that the teams need them to do
there's similar problems with the bands
to be honest because we do have have one
of the bands at the moment and and if
you have a chat with the guy that
operates it uses it on a daily basis
it's really difficult so we need the
technology to move up for it to be fit
for our
purpose
sorry
we've got to have confidence in in the
in the system and structure that we've
decided to do this we spent a lot of
time with peter rewriting how the whole
pid system was down scored evaluated etc
secondly there's been a workshop for
members to look at it um this is not the
committee to try to
unpick
the prioritization of justification of
the individual pins um because that's
been done by a wider group
and spent a lot of time on it yeah
exactly
just because you know it doesn't come up
with the answer that some people like
well that's i'm afraid that's why we're
yeah here i got the um
the agenda for the 7th of december the
capital print review it was a review
never remember is only 14 of the 36
counsellors actually attended that
meeting i keep a record of it
and one of the outcomes that came from
professional langford here was that
could we keep a blank spot to bring on
projects we think were important from
our own um
um
district our own awards that we
represent uh and what could be a
recommendation because it was only a
review meeting but it was clearly stated
that how do we get
victoria park in because victoria park
or the parks weren't even listed on the
i a to j
projects that were on that agenda
and we did ask if we could keep a blank
spot for you know for people to suggest
what they consider to be important
bits at the time
okay
um
chair where the invites went out with 36
members if 14 with only 14 members
uh while they belong participated you
know
we try to facilitate things more members
to come along to
uh but keeping blank spots for members
to put things forward you will probably
have 36 different projects come forward
how do you then define which one takes
precedence that's why we've got the
paid process and then now you reverse
the question
through to our chief exec
how can
members
raise
the issue of what kids should come onto
the agenda so that they get chance in
timely process well i think
what steve said that members have been
given the chance
they've been given the chance and and
only 14 wanted to bother you but i'm
going back to this 14
what the 14 were given on the 7th of
december was nothing at all about
victoria park and yet members raised it
at the time
how do they get timely into the process
that there is a bit um
it's all there is
okay i apologize i haven't read that
then that's right to say that that
demonstrated that work because that has
come forward
pennington has said what the process is
what is the process if we members want
projects to go forward i'd like to know
it seems to be the officers decide about
the projects
if you wanted something done to victory
about you would you would go to adrian
yeah
so there's no involvement there
and one of the issues on kazakhstan
factors
to elude is we're obviously responsible
for insurance yeah
and you know the estate manager has to
take a consideration of health and
safety we believe it's a passion in a
dangerous state
you know that impacts on our insurance
we get lots of claims in the church
and organically that will always be the
case officers must
put forward the majority of um
veggies you wouldn't necessarily know
the state of riverbank house boiler or
something like that
organically would be is the case the
estates manager will know most about the
infrastructure the council has more so
than i will or anybody else but that and
enrich it although
movements in technology and recycling
see what they'll have to put a capital
bid into but we went in
2016-17 to get the new vehicle fleet you
know there was a switch around the
service so i don't think it's unusual
the majority of capital projects come
from officers
claire
thank you and just to sort of
look at this as a whole
council members set a strategy
they determine the projects that are the
priorities for this authority and charge
the officers
with the
projects that need to be delivered which
convert into pigs
so therefore
we dictate
what we want done
at a strategic level
we don't as members actually prepare the
kids
um
recognizing this
might
comment about anything that hasn't
stored highly enough i quite
i concur with my colleague here that
you set the process
um you can't just overturn it however
the caveat to that is with the pigs that
fall below this store being referred
back to offices for further work or
refinement
that is the ability to look at things
that haven't met
the bar exactly and to look at why they
haven't met the bar so i think
the recommendations in this report are
robust
in the fact that it's covered um that
possibility
i would uh you know we've heard
challenges about 46 000 for pathways
i personally would challenge and i might
put my head above the parapet
but the 176 for victoria park
i think is
potentially a gross underestimate
for the amount of area that you are
covering and i say that without the
knowledge of what the kid was actually
uh planning to because i wasn't part of
that process so i bow to the wisdom of
everybody but uh it seems a little life
to me
so i rest there thank you
thank you very much
anyway
sorry
wait a minute
adrian redwood was there and he said
that the planning application has
already
gone in to committed already been
submitted all of the necessary reports
and investigations have taken place
which presumably probably costs a few
thousand pounds to find out exactly what
needs doing
we're the planning authority we should
be setting an example in our town centre
as we go around to different businesses
saying that their buildings aren't up to
scratch and they need to make them
better and yet we've got
the pannier market in the state of this
disrepair in the centre of great tourism
and
and we've got the economy at the top as
a top priority in our strategic plan and
yet in our town center we've got one of
our main buildings
looking
well
said it's only going to get worse
something needs to be done to it so you
might as well he said he just needs the
agreement from the council and it can
all go ahead
and happen so i would propose we put
that one to go through next because it
might end up costing us more in the long
run if we let it get even worse
we're not here to look to propose
anything to goldman
now s the other ones that are there that
you're saying about it
you know it's gone back surely it's gone
back to
it's there it's on the list it just
hasn't met the 65 thresholds
have to do quite a lot of that uh work
to prepare the page anyway uh it's kind
of generally accepted with capital
projects you have to do
work in advance to identify the cost to
spec out what is required otherwise you
can't put a document
a document together so agents you know
submitting
uh planning applications finding out
some of the details he would need to do
that otherwise you'd end up with uh
pigs without any kind of realistic parts
i know
that sounds a little bit odd because you
don't actually know the cost to go
pretend anyway um but that's
that's kind of part of the process and
with capital projects it's a lot less
done at risk on that basis
it's a great two-star listed building it
needs something needs to be done to it
at some point it's only going to get
worse because more money then i'd say
that we should be doing it now
[Music]
of cancers that aren't dissatisfied with
it we're all prepared to accept when
things fall below the line
but let's see let's let's look at the
clay strategy this was going to be the
panacea it work
meeting after meeting on it and here we
are with victoria park
big population
a lot of children
and they've got to travel to either
torrington or westwood
i sense the frustration and i'm sure
these officers
realize those counsellors have been
speaking about victoria for a long long
time
and yet his system failed him
and that's the truth here he actually
failed the marking system how it's done
is not working well finally
you
the project score on this
is not necessarily making a judgment on
the on the
title of the project he's actually
making a judgment on the on the quality
of the case that we put forward and at
the moment the the view of the reviews
was that the
quality of the case that was put forward
not that they don't need playing stuff
but actually
the plan that's been put forward at the
moment
isn't good enough quality
so therefore it didn't it didn't make
the necessary threats
exactly
we cannot do every single pig that comes
into this council and this is one of the
reasons that that we made this so that
it could be scored properly
you know how can we sit here keep
looking at this pig that pig oh well i
want this [ __ ] i want that bit come on
you can't do them all
we have not got the money
we've got a whole play strategy in place
we made it a priority
this is construction detail real cost
we're getting into an argument we're not
we're not going to have no arguments
over this
we've been through the play strategy
before and everything else and steve do
you want to say something yeah i'm just
going to come back um so the play
structure is one aspect of your
strategic plan so victoria park for
example just read your housing strategy
so to score highly
so you split the pit the paid process
the split
scoring methodology um into a number of
sections each having a maximum score of
25
so to get 25 against the strategic plan
you'd have to meet all the strategic
plan priorities or have
a statutory responsibility which clearly
it doesn't
on your value for money element it has
to generate um substantive external
funding which it doesn't so it's already
starting to score low on lower on half
who score
uh the other bit the other element is
around project management and delivery
again has to be very clear highly
deliverable and excellent project
management and then there's the evidence
of requirement to score highly it would
have to have a high level of community
consultation which it probably hasn't at
this stage which is why these things can
then go referred back to your officer
team to look at them in more detail to
explore areas of funding
it's there to
back to the officers to try to improve
it
you know then it can come back i'm sure
he can come back doug what do you want
to say i just bought those asia with
reference to
the comments that
had just said about
value for money
park and the 10 pence who match that so
you know there is there is a
considerable amount of money that's you
know already put in my partner
organizations to support this and i
think that needs to carry some weight
moving forward if it's not
[Music]
to generate a score of 10
out of 25 you'd have to have
um somewhere around 25 percent of
external funding to generate 15 it would
have to have 50 percent of external
funding and that's the scoring mechanism
that the committee has
devised
so external funding is in there but
given relative weight into the amount
against the total cost of the project
but i'm sure the office is looking at it
again i think
because we sent it back
has been sent here
no no that's right but nothing spoken
yet
yeah cheryl yeah so there's a community
group set up trying to raise funds as
well as
trying to get um council money towards
it and like you say there's a british
trafficking town council
but it's easier for them to get external
grass if they see that the council are
committed to improving it as well so if
we are to agree a certain amount of
money not to cover the whole thing but a
set amount of money then they're more
likely to match fund it and
we'll end up with a better place space
because
we'll be able to get more grants because
they know that we're committed to it but
if we're staying there we don't want to
put anything towards it because there
aren't any grants
there's not enough ground going towards
it then it will let it stay like it is
at the moment no one will want to put
money into it because they think that no
one's committed to it so that's why we
need to put it forward and say yes we're
willing to put forward this certain
amount of money
to improve it and as claire that's the
hudson said it might be an underestimate
but it might cost
to get it looking exactly how we want it
it might cost even more money and that's
where we get the external grants to get
to that stage
but if we say no we're not committed
first of all when you're a counsellor
you're going to see other councils do it
and i took my two grandchildren to
farnham park and they are evil this is
now 11 next birthday
to play on the seesaw
and the council has taken the sea souls
out because they can't afford to fund
them any longer so there is choices
there when it comes to to either funding
or not funding from that point of view
secondly i would get voicemail
having abstain on the pressure out of
voting and i noticed that at our last
full council we voted to spend 33k on
the ice machine at the fish stock which
only scored
53 points
can i ask our solicitor is there a
procedural way that if there is a
feeling for some strong capital
expenditure
we can bring it through as a notice of
motion at full council to put before cnr
that we look at the specific issue if we
argue there is social value as well as
capital value um mandatory value
discretionary value um is there a
procedural way given the strength of
feeling about victoria mark at avenue to
develop this discussion that's my dream
what making sure
i'm basically
how our whole budget is set and and
every time a decision is made i don't
want to be onto my financial colleague
cemetery
something else has to change within our
our budget
um so all of these things can
effectively be done
but you have to bear in mind there's a
squeeze in the toothbrush
basically yeah i mean you seem to
forgotten david's presentation which
i've alluded to
we've got nothing in the park exactly
four two thousand
twenty three twenty four onwards
well i'm guilty of that
person we know that now
you know peter's saying we've got
potential pressures of 3.7 million
pounds
in the capital going forward
there's nothing else we've basically
identified all the possible sources
probably going forward all the pressure
don't need to put aside for the vehicles
and essentially we get through 22-23
then after
the potty's
empty
you know we maybe go out and get
external countries off the victoria park
some of what council coughlin has
mentioned perhaps is actually more of a
bid
and when i i'm personally one of the
three people designated by internal
office which is approved by full council
to store the pits yes and my criteria on
uh partners i didn't feel the paid
itself was particularly worked up to the
highest standard if that had in higher
versions of
um external funding which had been
secured and we had grant operators to
that effect then our scoring may have
changed
based on the trying to this
this
working with this committee sat
i'm not sure where else i was supposed
themselves um steve and council games
are supposed to do we set it we scored
it based on the criteria the working
party sat down with my colleague peter
no okay ken do you
do would you like to make a comment
she's laid in the trenches
i'm sure
anyway
we've got some recommendations here
nobody else wants to say anything really
i just did that more than observation
that i mean
i'll put my hand up there i was on that
but
[Music]
and seeing how many things good things
come
because you know there is as we said
there is a finite amount
here
and and it really is trying to get the
best value for
our money
and the best you know use of the
resources that we have and it is always
a difficult process to choose one
against the other and the idea of the
process is to kind of give an encourage
you know bigger perspective
to get the best for the whole yeah best
value for mine
okay
right okay we've got some
recommendations here
um
shall we take him individually or do all
four on block
sorry you want to take them individually
everybody wants to take some individual
or
proposal and secondary taking them
individually or
on block proposal from block i'm
proposing
one all those in favor have taken it on
block
two
six seven eight
okay
right
move on
thank you boris
[Music]
okay all those in favor
hey
those again
thank
[Music]
thanks peter
40.
we're on now budget special
march we've got the qbr three empty
homes
janet is coming back with the empty
homes um
laser services update grass maintenance
i
the legislation was passed but i
actually think there's some prep work to
be done before that
so i i don't think it should disappear
completely it should still be on there
i agree it's not maybe
the most median
but
it shouldn't fall down radar
that the government legislation for
the new procurement rules has been
delayed
so we understand that that's not going
to be
early years as we anticipated
but i believe that the
meeting when we agreed to look at it we
set up the working group i think it was
councillor newton and yesterday getting
some
um expertise in to give us an overview
of social value and what is meant by
that to the working group
now we've been we've got a a linkage
with excellent city council um who help
our procurement team with
google they've got a procurement expert
so
they're procurement experts with me to
come along to a working group meeting to
give the
working group an update and an overall
information on
social media and also what is being
proposed across them
so i can liaise with the chair and the
working group on a date for when that
person can come in and meet with the
working group to give an update on sort
of value i guess my query is
when do you want it do you want it now
and then wait for
the
legislation to come through or do you
want to wait a little bit that it's
closer to when the legislation is coming
through
the legislation
because otherwise we're a lose sight or
the information you get next to will
become
distant parts that would have forgotten
yeah
did you want to say some good thing well
i would say not that way the only reason
why is that actually i think
[Music]
do we know when this thing's gonna come
down
they're expecting some draft
um legislation out of this year
yeah the full won't be until next year
so
um
i mean like in the age of the chair when
you start thinking an email around
[Music]
[Music]
go forward
it's not a problem
for this one
i think you've been approved
okay
came through from full council on
monday was that for this committee
what's up with another street
[Music]
[Music]
for
the
uh housing cr cnr
oh i thought i thought the committee
refunded to rns
[Music]
that's the end of our meeting today and
thank you all for coming